- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Seyla Benhabib,
who is the Eugene Meyer
professor of political science
and philosophy at Yale University
and director of the program in
ethics, politics, and economics.
She is the author of numerous books,
including Critique, Norm and Utopia,
Situating the Self,
The Reluctant Modernism of Hannah Arendt,
and The Claims of Culture.
She is the 2004 Tanner
Lecturer at UC Berkeley.
Seyla, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- [Harry] Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Istanbul, Turkey,
and I came to the United States in 1970,
but basically I was raised in Istanbul.
I went to school there,
the English High School for
Girls, for secondary school,
junior high basically,
and the American College
for Girls for senior high.
- And how and when did
your family come to Turkey?
- My family came to Turkey, as we say,
in 1492, along with the Ottomans
when they conquered
Istanbul from Byzantium.
And my ancestors are Sephardic Jews
who fled Spain, excuse me, in 1492,
when the Inquisition was
forcing Jews, basically,
either to convert or,
you know, decimating them
or forcing them to go underground.
And at the time, the Ottoman Empire
had a policy of giving refuge
to the Jewish community
escaping from Spain.
Why or how this policy was there,
whether it was an attempt also to capture
Eastern Mediterranean trade or whether
it was some ancient rule of hospitality,
but in any event, as far back as we know,
we came to Turkey at about 1492,
you know, during that time.
- And looking back, how do you think
this family history shaped
your thinking about the world?
- Well, I think that it makes me aware
of the fragility of good
political institutions.
I never take them for granted.
I am always attentive to the ways in which
particularly collective
ideologies of purity,
be it religious purity, racial purity,
or national purity, can go wrong.
I mean 1492 is also the period
that is referred to, for example,
in Spanish history, as
the Second Reconquista,
or the reconquering of
Spain from the Muslims.
And it is the consolidation of Catholic,
the Catholic kingdom
of Spain and authority.
And at the same time, its consequence
was the decimation of
first the Jewish minority
and also, to a lesser extent,
the triumph over the Muslim community.
So this makes me very distrustful
of, basically, collectivist
ideologies of any kind.
It makes me very attentive
to what I would like to call
practices of good governance
and state-building,
and makes me realize how fragile
and unpredictable sometimes, you know,
the course of history is.
So it may be not an accident that in the,
more in the last decade, I
have been writing more and more
on questions of refuge,
asylum, citizenship
and cultural conflict and
multiculturalism and nationality,
because I have so much that
I can also bring to this.
I mean my nerve ends are constantly
sensitive to these issues.
- We'll talk about that
later in the interview,
your current work, but let's,
let me ask you about your parents.
How do you think, looking back,
that they shaped your views of the world?
Did they just build on this history
that we've just discussed?
- Well I think that my,
the family background is in some ways
quite typical, I think, for
diasporic Jewish communities.
I have a grandfather who was a rabbi.
But my father could not
even complete his studies
as the Second World War broke out.
My parents were married in 1939.
My father was, for a brief period,
inducted into the Turkish Army,
and then it turned out that Turkey
stayed out of the war
and declared neutrality.
And my father subsequently
became a businessman.
And my mother's history is that she was
educated, actually, in a
French elementary school,
and then she went to
an Italian high school.
So we grew up, you know, with a background
of multiple European languages at home.
I mean at any one point in time
we could shift from Turkish
into French into Ladino,
and then came English,
and my mom also spoke Italian.
So we were very much, I
think that what I would
say about the family background is that
we were very much, you
know, part of Europe.
All these European currents of thought,
you know, sort of literature and ideas,
went through us even though we were
living in a primarily Muslim,
and to many understandings, quote unquote,
an Oriental, you know, community.
We were part of this legacy.
But my mother in particular was someone
who really could have studied further
if the circumstances of being
a woman at that point
would have permitted.
I mean, for example, my mother's mother
never went to school, she
didn't know how to read,
which is always a remarkable fact for me
when I think back that, you know,
her granddaughter is, you
know, a professor at Yale.
And you know, my grandmother, basically,
did not know how to read.
But my mother was offered a scholarship
by Mussolini's Italy to go
and study history of art,
and of course, my grandmother said
you are going absolutely nowhere,
and she was married off the next year.
So I come from this mixture of, you know,
Oriental and Western values,
where women were educated
but then married off
at the age of 19 and 20,
where you went a certain way
but you didn't go all the way.
You didn't push the envelope all the way.
- And how did this diversity,
which you must have lived everyday,
now I'm talking about sort of
being in the Istanbul community,
that must have been an amazing experience
in terms of sensitizing you to issues,
concerns, and sensibilities
that we're just now encountering
in big parts of the United States.
- Istanbul itself was, and
I think it's lessened now,
but it was one of the big cosmopolitan
centers of, in a way, the old Europe.
I mean, we not only had
this diversity of languages
and affiliations, if
you wish, in the family,
but the schools that I went to,
there were a lot of girls of Greek origin,
ethnic Greeks who had remained in Turkey.
I had Armenian friends growing up,
and this is something that people
who know about the Armenian massacres,
for example, do not realize,
that there were still a substantial number
of Armenians who remained in Turkey.
I do not have the exact numbers,
but I believe that they were
probably, in size, as large
as the Jewish community,
which was about 100,000 when
I was growing up in the 1950s.
And there were also
children of various foreign
diplomats, teachers, embassies.
And so Istanbul was basically a city
in which you heard five or
six different languages.
You could encounter,
you know, neighborhoods,
varieties of food and taste.
So the very concept of, you know,
cosmopolitanism in multiculturalism,
there's also that aspect of it in the old,
in the older metropolises, you know,
a city like Istanbul, that
was quite remarkable I think.
- And then where were you educated
once you left Turkey and
came to the United States?
- I came to Brandeis
University with a scholarship.
- The Wien.
- Yes, funded by Larry Wien,
the Wien International Scholarship, right.
And I was there for two years
and did my degree in philosophy
and then moved to Yale from there.
- And what drew you to
political philosophy?
Was it the teachers that you had or what?
- No, I think it was more,
it was probably several things.
I mean, first I think it was
simply the biographical background
and always, you know, the sense of
sort of being in Turkey but
not really being, you know,
Turkish in the ethnic or national sense
and negotiating those
conflicts as I was growing up.
But then, of course, 1968,
the Student Movement.
And I was in the American
College for Girls,
which was an elite, you
would say, junior college,
and the news of the Vietnam
War was coming to us.
And we had many teachers
who themselves were,
in many cases, draft evaders who had come
to teach in Istanbul
in an American school,
and had refused to go to the war.
So the news of the Vietnam War
was basically what we talked about
during our lunch hours.
And I remember seeing those pictures
of, you know, babies
with napalm, you know,
who had been exposed to
napalm bombing and et cetera.
And I think that there was
a speedy process of politicization.
So not only then there
was the Vietnam War,
there was the Student Movement,
and in Turkey in particular,
there was an emergence
of an independent left,
a very significant
mobilization among the workers.
So history sort of was
knocking at the door,
and if you were a thoughtful
or reflective person,
you had to focus on the political issues.
But of course, you know,
I'm sure it was also
a personal affinity that drew me.
I mean I was always
interested in philosophy.
I think I have a mind that
tends towards abstractions,
but I also am interested in seeing
the way in which these
abstractions and principles
are at work or play themselves
out in the course of history.
So I would say that,
beginning with 1968, you know,
both the student movement,
anti Vietnam War movements,
the workers movements in Turkey,
you know, politics has just
never left my life since then.
- And what was your dissertation on?
- My dissertation was on Hegel.
It was on Hegel's philosophy of right.
It was on his philosophy of the state
and it was called Natural Right and Hegel,
an essay on modern political philosophy.
So it seems in many ways
I was asking the same questions,
and I think I have been
asking the same questions.
I think most people who do philosophy,
I really believe, have a certain
central question, an existential question
that accompanies them most of their lives.
And you write different works,
you write different books,
but I believe that you're basically
asking the same question.
And for me, the issue,
starting already in that work,
was how to reconcile universalistic
principles of human rights,
autonomy, and freedom
with our concrete particular identities
as members of certain
concrete human communities
divided by language, by
ethnicity, by religion.
And so I went to Hegel's
philosophy of right
because Hegel is really one of the first
systematic thinkers in modernity
who says, look, we have three
principles in the state,
there is morality, there is legality,
and then there is ethical life.
You know, morality is what we all
should have in common as
moral, rational beings,
legality is the system of
rights under which we live,
and ethical life is
basically the structure
of a family, the market, civil society,
and the concrete state to which we belong.
So that's what I focused on,
and it seems to be, for the last 30 years,
I have been circling around this question
in one way or another.
And you know, giving it different answers.
But the question seems
to me to have remained.
- And in a second we'll talk about,
you know, where you are now,
what the current iterations
are, to use your word.
But before we do that,
could you help our audience
understand what a
political philosopher does?
At one level it's a silly question,
but also I think it may be a way
to then talk about your
current work actually.
- What does a political philosopher do?
I think to be a political philosopher,
it's more a vocation than a career.
I mean, we can be in universities,
and in some contexts
one can be a journalist,
one can be a human rights activist.
But basically, it is,
I would say that it is
a vocation for thinking
about the political.
Not just politics, the day
to day in our politics,
but about the phenomenon of the political,
that all known human communities
of any degree of complexity
organize themselves according
to certain principles
of justice, equality,
reciprocity and authority.
I mean, these are
anthropological universals.
You know, you can go to
ancient Indian communities,
to Aboriginal communities,
there will be a system of power
and a system of legitimation
according to which goods are distributed,
offices are distributed,
and rewards are arranged.
So in that sense, the political,
understood as this domain,
is fundamentally constitutive
of our lives as humans.
And that's why, for example,
Aristotle defined the human animal
as the zoon logon echon, that is to say,
the animal who is capable
of reasoned speech.
And to be capable of reasoned speech,
it means also that we are capable
of persuading others, and that we are,
together, capable of
forming a system of values
and a system of principles
on using our reasoned speech.
So, in that sense, the political
is fundamental to the human condition.
I mean, particularly today, you know,
we live in such a moment of
the decline of the political.
You know, we live in a period when
the political is simply understood either
as strategic bargaining of various games,
the way a lot of political
science understands the political
is various interest groups
positioning themselves
as trying to get, you know, various gains,
whether material, office, or authority,
or we have, I think, a
culture at the moment,
particularly in this country,
a culture that personalizes the political
and reduces it to the
sensationalistic and to the intimate
so that the political disappears
in the sensationalist stories
about the individuals.
So I think we are at
a very troubled moment
as far as political culture is concerned.
So the vocation of the
political philosopher
becomes more and more difficult.
I mean, we are part of, I would say,
the process of collective
cultural reflection.
And some of the work that we do
is very close to cultural criticism.
The other work that we do
may be more systematic and reconstructive
in terms of trying to understand
what the principles of justice are
for, you know, modern societies.
What, you know, distribution should
look like in our kinds of societies,
what is the basis of authority.
But in particular I think that
political theorists must remind one
of the significance of the political
as opposed to what counts as,
you know, politics in everyday world.
I mean, to the degree to which, you know,
sort of, politics has almost become
a pejorative term in our
culture, increasingly.
I mean, politicking.
It's not something to which
we attribute a lot of value.
But that itself is a
major issue and a problem,
and it is really a kind of, you know,
decline in public culture
to have come to that point.
- What are the prerequisites
of doing this kind of work?
Obviously abstract thinking
is very crucial to these endeavors.
But how much are you influenced,
you clearly draw on tradition and history.
As you just said, you're going back
to the themes that recur but
in fact are being forgotten,
really, because of the processes today.
- I mean, obviously you need
a certain kind of training
in the history of political
thought, first of all.
I mean, you know, there is a tremendously
rich and important tradition,
and I personally regret that I do not know
as much about the history
of political thought
outside the Western tradition.
I mean I myself am more of a specialist,
particularly, on European
and German thought,
and it took me many years
to acquire the kind of,
let's say, German language
proficiency that I have.
And there is a certain kind of dedication
and training, first of all, you know,
to this tradition that you have to have,
but there also has to be
a passion about politics.
I mean, there has to be a
passionate involvement with it.
You must care about the
world around you, I think,
to really want to bring the principles
of philosophy to bear upon the world,
rather than simply seeing
the world as a kind of
fallen, you know, it's a mess,
because most of the time,
if you read the newspaper,
it certainly appears as a mess.
And you know, the tendency to want to
sort of look beyond it maybe be great.
That's why most philosophy
actually sort of
looks beyond the world to something else.
But the political philosophy
is always in a strange situation.
She is always caught in mediating
very abstract principles
with concrete realities
such as to think through,
to use Arendt's term, what we are doing.
And to think through what we are doing
and where we are going in light
of this abstract principle,
of course it involves
training, but as I say,
I think it also involves
a passion and a vocation.
- And you're also, as you just suggested,
affected by events and the chaos
that those events are producing,
and in some ways, it's
an ordering process,
a putting together of the facts
by referring back to works that we think
are not relevant in the first
instance, but can be made so.
You use the term, in your
lectures, iterations.
Talk a little about that, what that is.
It's rethinking, I guess.
- Yes, yes.
The term iteration seems at first,
very simply, like repetition.
You know, you reiterate a phrase,
you reiterate in a song, let's say.
You have the jingle, the
lyric, that keeps coming back.
But I think that iterations
are complex processes
of appropriating and
transforming at the same time.
I mean these are cultural
and intellectual processes
whereby at times it may seem as if
we are simply repeating the original,
but what we are really doing
is we are creating new meaning.
And these processes of
iteration are particularly
visible in certain domains
like legal interpretation.
And this is interesting because,
in any liberal democracy with
a constitutional tradition,
we live through the reinterpretation,
reappropriation, and the
reiteration of the past.
In other words, what makes a tradition,
a body of doctrine, a body of law,
alive for us in the
present is our capacity
to appropriate this body of law,
and yet, at the same time,
to think it through in the present.
So these are processes of
creative rearticulation
through which, really,
traditions continue themselves,
legal doctrine maintains itself,
and I would even say that
this capacity for iteration,
and I refer to this in some other works
as the narrative
constitution of identities,
I think that this capacity for narrativity
is fundamental to the human condition.
I mean, maybe another way to put it
would be that we are storytelling animals.
And when we are no longer capable
of telling stories about ourselves,
about our traditions,
about our lives together,
something terrible
dries up in the culture.
I think that the culture ceases
to be a live legacy for it
when we can no longer tell the new story,
when we can no longer reiterate
it and reappropriate it.
So I'm interested in understanding
those moments of appropriation
and the emergence of the new,
how when it seems as if we're really
just continuing the old,
but continuing the old
is always reinterpreting it from
the standpoint of where we are at today.
- Do women have a unique contribution
to contribute to this dialogue?
I know that in contemporary
political science,
some of the great
thinkers have been women.
I mean you've worked on Hannah Arendt,
and we'll talk about her in a minute,
but Judith Shklar, Hanna Pitkin here,
at Berkeley and so on.
So comment on that, because there are,
is there an interface here between
being a woman and doing theory well?
Or was it merely that theory was a place
that women were allowed to occupy
before the walls of
discrimination came down?
- That's really a complex
and fascinating question.
I mean I do think it is remarkable
that, among all theoretical fields,
I mean, you know, there aren't that many
women in theoretical physics
or theoretical mathematics,
that political philosophy has produced
significant names in the past century
and hopefully also into our century.
Now some of the
individuals whom you named,
like, you know, Hannah
Arendt, Judith Shklar,
who was my senior colleague
and whom I had the pleasure
to meet at Harvard,
and I worked with her for several years.
- And you taught at
Harvard, we should mention.
- Yes, I did, right.
And Hanna Pitkin, whom
I do not know personally
but whose work I greatly
admire and respect.
Some of them have reflected upon
the particular juncture in their
own work and political philosophy.
I think that there is a
certain, maybe, puzzle
that women bring to the world of politics
which has always seemed so much
an exclusively male world.
And even today, in very simple numbers,
when you look at the
level of representation
in the House of Representatives,
in our Congress,
or you know, in most
parliaments all over the world,
there is no parity anywhere.
And the number of women
in the political sphere,
usually it's somewhere
between 10 to 25 to 30 percent
in the most successful social
democratic legislatures.
For example, in Sweden
and Denmark and so on
you will find higher numbers
of women participating.
So it has seemed, I think,
for a very long time,
that the political has been
an exclusively male domain,
and as Arendt puts it,
the political seems to be
concerned with honor,
recognition in the public sphere,
competition, which are very different
than the virtues of the private sphere,
to which women have been
historically assigned,
which is more about continuing life,
nurturing the young,
attentiveness to everyday-ness.
You know, the virtue of the
public sphere may be honor,
but the virtue of the private
sphere is care and concern.
So it could be that, because of this
understanding of the political
as also an exclusively male domain,
that women who have been outsided,
who have been marginals,
have reflected upon this
and have reflected upon this critically.
It's almost as if, you know,
if you are excluded from something,
sometimes you can have an almost better
and more creative critical
perspective on it.
So I think that, to a large extent,
women political
philosophers have reflected
upon the domain of the political,
partially also realizing its illusions,
partially realizing that it is
one sphere among others in human activity.
But there has also been this
heightened concern about it.
What is it really?
I mean, Hanna Pitkin herself,
who is also a feminist
theorist, talks about this.
But for example, in Hannah Arendt's work,
you have these categories of the public
and the private very clearly articulated.
And she always praised the
public and the political,
in many ways, over the private.
But on the other hand,
only she could have written
in the way which she has written
about the private and the intimacy,
you know, or about the
principle of natality.
That every child that is born
introduces a new principle of freedom,
and that there is no way to predict
what any human being will bring.
This is before cloning and programming.
But natality, I mean,
how does one introduce that
into political thought?
Inevitably, there are certain
gender experiences there
that are flowing into the theory.
- Your current work and the
subject of your lectures
focus on identifying the processes
by which universal norms assume
an authoritative position,
though they're outside the
boundaries of the nation-state.
That is a first rendering, on my part,
of the complicated work.
And interestingly, you
relate this subject matter,
in a very important
way, to unsolved puzzles
in the work of Arendt and
Kant in your lectures.
So this is, so as you
grapple with these problems,
and let's talk about those problems,
it's very clear you
turned to that tradition
to find the iterations or to
help create the iterations.
Talk a little about that,
why you got interested in the subjects
of migration, humanitarian
intervention, and so on,
where there is a search for legitimating
these new universal norms in a context
that transcends the nation-state.
- I think maybe the best
way to talk about this
may be by going back to 1948
and the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
After the experience of two world wars,
I think that the nations of this world
entered a learning process
where it was established
that self-governing nations,
whatever their differences,
had to respect a minimum set
of rights and universal norms.
So the 1948 declaration
initiates what I call
the rise of an international
human rights regime.
And since then, the
number of international
treaties and conventions,
the convention, let's
say, on the elimination
of all forms of
discrimination against women,
the convention against
cruel and unjust punishment,
the convention on the rights of the child,
the international covenant on
social and economic rights,
civil and political rights.
If you look at all of this,
there are numbers and numbers
of treaties and conventions
that have been signed and ratified,
not by all the nations of the world,
I think we have about 190 to 195
recognized nation-states
or political entities.
Not all of them have signed it.
In some cases, two-thirds
do and one-third does not.
But there is a new moment in the evolution
of the international
community where we are
going beyond what would be simply called
international law based on treaty rights.
So for example, let's
say the U.S. and Japan,
the U.S. and China have
a number of treaties
and international
obligations to one another
that can range from trading
to the hunting of tuna fish, et cetera.
Those are international treaty obligations
that nations can voluntarily
undertake with one another.
This has been the norm, also,
of much of international law.
But the kinds of human rights treaties
and the kinds of norm conventions
that I'm talking about
initiate a new moment in that
these are now almost a kind of,
I will say very carefully, they are almost
a quasi-constitutional structure
for the international community at large,
where what the nations
are obliging themselves to
are not, you know, how much
tuna fish can be hunted
or how much Chinese exports can come in
and, you know, how they are regulated,
but very fundamental norms, right?
The convention on the elimination
of discrimination against women.
I mean, think of the many countries
that are signatories of these
where the internal
practices of these countries
can hardly be assessed to have
ceased discrimination against women.
Now what is this moment in human history
when, increasingly, there
is a juridification,
a constitutionalization, of a set of norms
and the fact that
nation-states acknowledge them?
Now, for me, I'm describing
this as the cosmopolitan moment,
as the emergence of cosmopolitan norms.
And this is different than
international trade law,
international treaties,
but it is genuinely, I think,
novel development for the human community.
And yet, at the same time that we have
the emergence of these treaties
and norms that are becoming
more and more accepted
by the nations of the world,
there is also the
fundamental contradiction
that the nation-states are
the addressees of these norms,
they are the signatories.
When you look at whose signature
is under these treaties,
it's always the state.
And yet, at the same time,
these norms themselves
constrain the very action
of the states themselves.
In other words, the states
are both signatories,
and yet, at the same time,
they are constrained,
they are constrained by these very norms.
I mean, if Egypt signs the convention
on the elimination of
discrimination against women,
this has consequences.
So Egypt is both the
addressee of these norms,
but it also has consequences for the way
in which, let's say, the rights of women,
divorce, property, et cetera,
are dealt with in a country like Egypt.
So in my lectures, I try to reflect upon
the rise of cosmopolitan norms
and republican self-determination.
And for us in the United States,
these issues became particularly relevant
with the decision of the
Bush treaty to rescind
the participation in the
international criminal court,
their own treaty establishing
the international criminal court
on the basis of the argument
that this would give rise
to spurious and ill-founded
prosecution of American
civilians and military.
I do not agree with that argument,
but I think that we see, very clearly,
that there is a conflict,
and particularly for the United States
that spearheaded the development
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights
with Eleanor Roosevelt,
to find ourselves now
in this position of sort of, you know,
saying, oh well, we remain sovereign,
the world can go
cosmopolitan, but you know,
American law is sovereign.
I mean, this is simplifying it.
So I have been thinking
about these puzzles.
Now, very briefly, the
reason why I went back
to Kant and Arendt is that
they had a sense, particularly Kant
is famous for having written an essay
in 1795 called Towards a Perpetual Peace,
and it is an essay that articulates
certain conditions that
nations must respect
if there ever will be perpetual peace.
And Kant is very aware
that this is totally,
to some extent, the term perpetual peace,
it's also almost like, the
German term is ewigen frieden,
it's eternal peace, it's also
the peace of the cemetery.
So he's very aware of
the fact that, you know,
this is ironic, he says.
Nobody expects a philosopher to come out
and tell generals and kings, at his time,
I mean we're not talking about
democracies, this is 1795,
how to run the world and how
to articulate principles,
but if there is going to be
perpetual peace among nations,
here are the conditions
that I will lay out.
And he says the
constitution of every state
must be a republican constitution,
that is, it must permit representation,
and that the nations of the world
should move towards a
cosmopolitan federation
where they regulate their
relationships with one another
according to laws, that they should
increasingly seek a common body of laws.
And he also says, in the third definitive
article of perpetual
peace, that there is one
right that belongs to a human being
as a human being in the world community,
and that is the right hospitality.
That is, if someone comes upon your shores
through need or for commerce or barter,
and if their purposes are peaceful,
you cannot deny them access.
You cannot deny universal hospitality.
Also, in particular, if that
will mean their destruction.
So the right to universal hospitality,
that is, the right of human beings
to seek contact with one another,
to seek access to each other's land,
to seek access to resources,
is a fundamental human right.
It needs to be regulated and there is
a certain margin as to
how much, for example,
you owe to the stranger
who comes upon your land,
what kind of obligations do
you owe to this stranger.
I mean, Kant's own formulation is somewhat
more minimal than I would like it to be,
because he says you have
a right of visitation
but not a right of long-term stay.
The host can determine that.
And I would like to argue, actually,
that the human right to visitation
is more extensive than
Kant makes it out to be,
and that nations have stronger obligations
to asylees and refugees
which are different
than the obligations to immigrants.
But this is a fascinating beginning point.
- And what's really interesting,
he's writing several hundred years ago
and he's laying the groundwork
for theorists working today
to clear some of the confusion
about the issues of immigrants, refugees,
which we see every day in the headlines.
And in fact, really,
the European community,
I think you're suggesting,
in what I heard and what I read,
is a real site for experimentation
with regard to these matters today.
That is, you know, real politicians
acting in the real world,
having to make decisions,
which are changing the nation-state
and the limits it can impose without
consulting these cosmopolitan norms.
Is that fair?
- Oh, I think that that
is absolutely fair.
I mean, there is the Geneva Convention
on the status of refugees, 1952,
and its protocol added in the '60s.
And all states that are signatories
to the Geneva Convention
have the obligation
to conduct themselves vis-a-vis refugees
and asylum seekers in a particular way.
And the most important aspect of this
is that, if someone reaches your shores
and raises a claim to refuge and asylum,
you have an obligation.
You as the state have an obligation
to examine the veracity or
truthfulness of that claim
and reach a decision.
You have an obligation of what
is called non-refoulement.
That is to say, you cannot
send the refugee back
without having examined this claim.
You ought not send the refugee back
into the point of danger.
Now, everybody, you know,
in many ways, violates this.
I mean, what we do, for
example, with Haitian refugees
is that we catch them in
the high seas even before
they set foot upon the
continental United States,
because once they have done so,
the government is under an obligation
to conduct itself in various ways.
And even if it does not
respect it, it is liable,
legally, as a signatory
of the Geneva Convention,
for its treatment of refugees and asylees,
and various kinds of international groups
and other NGOs can in fact
take the government to task,
which, you know, which they have done.
So the method becomes preventing them
from setting foot on
soil in the first place.
Which is really quite
devious, and, of course,
we now see the criminalization
of all these issues
in the United States under
the Bush Administration.
There no longer is anything, really,
I mean all matters of refuge, asylum,
and also immigration have become
so much absorbed into,
you know, criminal law
with this notion of homeland security.
I mean I think that we are in the midst,
frankly, of a frightful mess
from the standpoint of international law,
which is being flouted, right?
Now the situation in Europe
is presenting itself somewhat differently,
precisely because, also,
the European nation-states
are forming the European Union.
And the consequence of
forming the European Union
is that internal border
controls have been eliminated.
That is to say, you can now, in principle,
you should be able to drive
from Krakow down to Lisbon
without internal border
controls, as a European citizen.
But the elimination of
internal border controls
does not mean that the question
of Europe's external borders is,
that issue has also been solved.
Continental Europe is a
very wealthy environment.
It has very extensive rights,
and for a lot of the refugees
and asylees of the world
it is a very desirable focus.
So you have had, over
the last number of years,
millions of people trying to enter
the boundaries of the European Union.
So, from Moroccans, Kurds, Africans
to people also from even
China, mainland China,
there has always been some crisis
about refugees and asylum seekers
within Europe at the moment.
But this has caught it
in a difficult moment.
Just as they are eliminating
internal borders,
they are in the situation of
having to draw external borders.
So there have been various agreements,
like Schengen and Dublin, that have,
you know, tried to control
refugees and asylees from coming in,
so that we see a very mixed picture
at the moment, within the European Union,
of great liberality
within the member states,
but rather harsh measurements developing
towards refuge and asylum seekers.
But the one difference here is that,
because of the various legal traditions
and because of the way in which
Europe subscribes also
to the Geneva Convention,
the practice of trying to sort of
maybe stop people in refugee centers
before they even touch
the European continent
has not been that successful.
I mean the Blair government is asking
for the establishment of so-called
refugee processing centers
in countries where
refugees are coming from,
but the European Union
has not accepted that,
because they realize it's
a violation of the Geneva Convention.
- So the interesting problem for you,
and it was a puzzle for Hannah Arendt too,
but not, in other words, in the sense that
she saw the need for the
rights you talk about.
But she saw also that, in the past,
these rights had been
guaranteed by the nation-state,
by the people coming together and making,
talking about we the people,
but in fact it was within a bounded area.
And what, the problem for our times
is that globalization is creating
movements of people, the need for
humanitarian intervention and so on,
where a base for cosmopolitan norms
exists outside the boundary of the state.
And so a lot of this that
we see going on this world,
that you were just discussing,
is, in a way, the iteration of the polity
as it grapples with these problems.
And by focusing on this, you're able
to move this discussion along,
beyond where Hannah Arendt
could take it, in a way.
Because the times have moved on, in a way.
Is that fair?
- Well I hope it's also true.
I would like to think so.
When I finished my book on Arendt in 1996,
I was actually looking at the distinction
between the public and the private
and her concept of the public space.
But by the time I finished the book,
I was fascinated by her concept
of statelessness and the
right to have rights.
This notion of the right to have rights,
and what she meant by this is that
the irony of developments
in the 20th Century
had been that, precisely
at the point at which
individuals did not seem
to have a nation or a state
to protect them, that precisely
at that point at which,
when the sheer fact of being a human being
ought to have entitled
one to certain rights
and to certain protections, it
seemed as if one had nothing,
that to be stateless was basically
to become a complete pariah,
and that to be a stateless person
was also to be rendered,
in a way, rightless.
But the whole notion of
universal human rights
is rights that accrue
to us or belong to us
in virtue of our humanity,
not in virtue of our
citizenship or membership.
So she was understandably very pessimistic
that the right to have rights
would ever be guaranteed
in an international system,
and basically she thought that
only the possibility of establishing
a political entity to which one belonged
would resolve this condition.
And she was thinking, of course,
of refugees from the Second World War,
Jewish refugees and stateless peoples.
And she said, although
she was not a Zionist,
let's admit the fact that it is only
the establishment of the state of Israel
that has, in effect,
made these individuals
into beings entitled to rights.
So her work, ended up,
to me, with an aporia,
that there was a problem and there was
a solution which she was
only half-hearted about,
because she did not think
that the nation-state
was a solution to everything.
The nation-state, let's say,
was the solution to the Jews,
but it created the Palestinian refugees.
So one group was saved
but the other group,
you know, emerged, and she
was very well aware of that.
So I started thinking about this.
And I decided, there were,
there have been developments,
developments in the arena of
international institutions,
in the arena of various conventions,
the Universal Declaration of Human Rights,
Geneva Convention, where
we have gone beyond
the point that Hannah
Arendt has articulated.
But what we have not
been able to deal with
remains the following problem.
Border crossings are still
a quasi-criminal activity
unless accompanied by the
right kinds of papers.
And there is one voice in me that says,
from a moral point of view,
the only justifiable argument is really
for a world without borders.
I don't think that that's
going to be viable,
you know, politically, and communities
will need to govern themselves.
There will need to be some borders,
but really, we are, again,
at a point when we have no way
of dealing with the
system of border crossing
in terms of quasi-criminal language.
So, on the one hand, in the global world,
we have an unprecedented
mobility of peoples.
We are aware of the needs
of refugees and asylees,
not to speak about the 30
million displaced persons
as a result of civil wars
within their own countries,
and yet the map that
we navigate, literally,
is the map of the nation-state.
And so we have no way,
as a world community,
of addressing this
problem of border movement
and trans-border justice, except through
the categories of the old nation state.
So what I am doing, really,
is I'm trying to problematize,
I'm trying to raise this dilemma
to people's consciousness.
And you know, to think it through.
You know, do I have any concrete
and specific solutions to offer to this?
I would say we need to move towards
decriminalization of border movements.
I think that one has to have a much more
universally anchored system of, you know,
refuge and asylum, and I would also plead
for the extension of municipal
or city rights for long-term residents.
And I just don't think that
it will be possible for us
to envisage a world
completely without borders,
although we can ideally work
closer and closer towards it,
because there is the question, still,
of democratic representation
and accountability.
So we are caught in this
puzzle of, as I say,
you know, sometimes people
think this is harsh,
but democracies require borders.
They require boundaries in the sense
that one needs to know who
is representative to whom
and who is accountable to whom.
So it's very difficult
to square the circle.
I mean, I think it is possible
to have an empire without borders.
I don't think it's possible to have
a democracy without borders.
And so this creates, you know,
the sort of philosophical
and moral dilemma
that I have been trying to
address in these lectures.
Can you reconcile cosmopolitanism
and democratic self-governance?
- And interestingly enough,
as a political philosopher,
you have to do what the
system works against,
that you were saying earlier, namely,
you have to go back and
look at the great issues
that we've, the political philosophers
have worked on through the years.
What is a citizen?
What is the power of the sovereign?
And so on.
These are the big questions
that, by focusing on them,
can help us kind of clarify
the current confusion
about what are the rights of man
versus what are the rights
of the citizen, and so on.
- Absolutely, because when
we read the newspapers,
I mean, you know, we are confronted
with images, news stories, you know.
We have all heard about Guantanamo Bay,
but how many of us really know
that one of the difficulties
about the situation
in Guantanamo Bay is that,
because the United States
is a signatory of the Geneva Convention,
particularly if there are regular,
quote unquote, prisoners of war,
and the question is who has
the status of being a prisoner of war.
As Colin Powell pointed
out before his voice
was drowned out six months ago,
we would be in violation of the fourth
article of the Geneva Convention
which requires that prisoners of war
be also permitted access to counsel.
And so, you know, the
way this administration
has dealt with it by saying that
these are basically illegal noncombatants,
that is, they do not represent
a regular enemy army which
we would have to recognize,
you know, in combat under
the Geneva Convention.
So, you know, the ordinary citizen looks
at something like this,
looks at a news item,
and says, well so, I mean, you know,
but what is at stake here?
But in order to understand
what is at stake,
we have to go back to these categories.
Let me just give you another
aspect of this issue.
I did not talk about
Guantanamo in the lectures,
but I could have, I
was focusing on Europe.
I mean, how many of us know
that Guantanamo is basically a base
that we have rented
from Cuba for 99 years?
But then the question is,
is it part of the sovereign United States
or is it not part of the
sovereign United States?
As we know, there is a
recent court decision,
a federal district judge,
that is challenging this notion that it is
not part of the sovereign United States,
because if it is part of
the sovereign United States,
they cannot hold the prisoners
without access to counsel,
without giving them the
writ of habeas corpus,
without letting them know for what reason,
on what basis, they are
being held accountable.
This is, in many ways,
such a sort of legal
and political quagmire,
not to say scandal.
But as ordinary citizens, to
be able to think about this,
we have to go back all the way
and understand the principles on which
we have to act as a nation.
So, in that sense, the history
of political philosophy,
it's always there with us,
whether we recall it or not.
- On that note, Professor Benhabib,
I wanna thank you very
much for taking the time
and being with us today on our program,
and really, for this
fascinating discussion
of the work of theory and the
implications of globalization.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.